e aí pessoal e afirmou que era tudo bem
com vocês você tinha prometido que o
próximo vídeo seria um vídeo normal
engraçado como sempre mas eu realmente
sentia necessidade de fazer esse vídeo
pra ajudar esta causa
todo mundo está sabendo o que aconteceu
em santa maria quando se fala em santa
maria já o clima já fica pesado que
aconteceu em santa maria tem uma boate
chamada boate que estava acontecendo uma
festa e parece que nessa festa tinha um
tipo de show pirotécnico que utilizava
fogo e esse fogo deve ter se espalhado e
algum material inflamável alguma coisa
assim que era o tour que resultou em um
incêndio na boate parece com muita gente
é sentir o cheiro de fumaça vem o fogo
todo mundo começou a correr tentou sair
pela mesma porta que os seguranças não
deixaram ninguém sair o incêndio começou
a tomar conta da boate e com tanta gente
lá dentro que aconteceu foi que até
agora foram registadas 245 mortos e eu
estava aqui navegando pela internet só o
que se fala agora de santa maria que
esclarece três coisas pra você que
acontece é que se você for olhar tudo o
que está se passando na internet por
conta desse incêndio você vai ver que
tem gente que está querendo criar
polêmica com esse tipo de coisa
um exemplo com a tragédia dessa com 245
pessoas mortas queimada tem nem facebook
falar assim a água do rio grande do sul
ele gosta de churrasco agora está em
churrasco pra [ __ ] quando a gente lê
esse tipo de coisa a gente fica a gente
fica sem saber o que pensavam a alma 10
nem colocar no twitter churrasco em
santa maria bombando gente deixa as
causas são coisa pra você tragédia não é
coisa para se fazer piada piada só é uma
piada
se alguém é triste falar de coisas
enquanto outros países têm de fazer
revolução para ajudar quando acontece
uma tragédia aqui no brasil se alguém
vender com fósforo na mão já está
inventando piada sobre fogo a segunda
coisa que eu queria esclarecer o
seguinte tem gente fazendo piada
preconceituosa gente importante que esse
tipo de coisa não deveria ter acontecido
em santa maria e se no nordeste que é
onde não tem vida inteligente eu prefiro
nem mencionar esse tipo de briga
vim aqui o vídeo porque eu tenho uma
coisa mais importante pra falar que esse
tipo de pessoa é bom a gente tem da
atenção né marca doença o que acontece é
o seguinte quando você dá atenção a esse
tipo de briga você tira a atenção do
foco principal que ajudará as vítimas
nessa parte do vídeo que era só falar
pra você que não é pra você dá ouvido
esse tipo de briguinha e nem ficar
movimentando ela na internet para
lembrar pra você que o foco principal é
ajudar as pessoas porque o tipo de
pessoa que inventa essa briguinha está
pouca ganhando porque está acontecendo
então de atenção deixa pra lá e ajude ea
terceira coisa é a seguinte tem gente
querendo comer vivo os seguranças que
não deixaram as pessoas saírem da boate
tá lógico entendo se eu tivesse um
familiar se eu tivesse lá eu tiver saído
vivo eu queria matar o cara desse agora
mas o negócio é que a parada não é bem
assim
gente segurança ele é treinado para não
deixar acontecer todo mundo com muita
gente tem pela saída bota mesmo tempo
seguranças não deixaram que isso saí
porque o trabalho de seguranças é deter
pessoas nenhum segurança em sã
consciência e deixar o pessoal morrer
queimada porque ela não pagou porque
pessoas que não estão em são consciência
não viram segurança de boate então pára
de criar polêmica na internet para de
criar coisas que desviam a atenção
porque o foco é ajudar tem marinha desta
forma sem polêmicas em um besta deixa
pra lá fei ajuda o setor passou o vídeo
todo fala de ajuda ajuda ainda não disse
nada é o seguinte aqui na descrição do
vídeo tem todos os dados para você
ajudar enquanto tem nenhum criando
polêmica na internet tem gente precisa
de doação de sangue lá com muita gente
na internação muita gente mesmo tempo os
medicamentos acabaram que ninguém espera
tantas vítimas então a falta de pirou na
falta é o analgésico a falta muita coisa
aqui na descrição desse vídeo tem o
telefone para contato e você for ligar e
informar por favor se você é dono de uma
empresa se você é dono de alguma coisa
que possa ajudar livro esse número e
pergunta o que é necessário
se você mora perto de santa maria se
você mora em santa maria é você também
pode chegar nesse número e tentar ajudar
se você é um enfermeiro
médico qualquer coisa tudo ajuda a gente
está todo aqui na descrição do vídeo não
para desviar a atenção do que é
realmente necessário e ajuda você gostou
desse vídeo você já sabe o que fazer
é só esperar essa notícia com uma pessoa
que ainda não sabe então essa querem
ajuda minha contribuição com isso deixo
aqui meus pesames pras famílias das
pessoas que estavam lá na borracha espia
obrigado acontece esse vídeo até aqui e